Chelsea saw the video of Adam and she
put this thing together I believe this
is on The Tick Tock is it on the tick
tock yeah on the tick tock 45 of working
women ages 25 to 45 by 2030 will be
non-married no kids single
I have no choice but to sedate myself
with drugs and alcohol lately I've been
loud and proud about my status as a
single unmarried childless wild woman
and apparently some men cannot handle
that every time I go on Instagram I
stumble upon sde morons like this guy
pontificating about how unhappy women
like me must be if you think that you're
going to be 45 years old no kids not
married and that you're gonna genuinely
be fulfilled in life because you made
money best of luck to you honey right
best of luck to you honey I'm sorry but
if the child free Joyride I'm on
triggers you here's a hint if you need
Daily Alpha content to remind you to be
Alpha you might not be an alpha take it
from an alpha and the truth is studies
show that single women live longer and
are
you want to know why because they wake
up every day and they don't have to
listen to like you anyway I
have to go because my single unmarried
is about to perform at my sold out
comedy show I'd invite you but there are
no tickets left bye
man it's so interesting because there
there's really a lot here uh first off
Adam's going into some actual numbers on
this stuff and we're going to give you
some more numbers on this related to
depression and a bunch more uh but what
he what he says there is if you want to
have a genuinely be genuinely fulfilled
in life and the question there for
Chelsea and by the way I don't mean this
in a in a purely judgmental sense I
truly don't everyone is an individual
and there are people there absolutely
are people who who are outside of the
norm right so if 90 of people let's say
uh want the same things like
fundamentally actually want the same
things to find a partner that makes them
happy and be fulfilled and hopefully
have a family and experience all of
those things that's probably what 90 of
the people actually want if you could
just sort of parse it down but of course
there are people on the margins who can
be fulfilled in other ways uh Patrick
bad David who is uh sasnik's on his uh
show every day uh said this on Twitter I
thought this was quite a good childless
women are 46 percent more likely to
report higher depression compared to
mothers some are childless by choice
some can't get pregnant people who try
so hard to appear Happy on the outside
are typically in a lot of pain she's
trying real hard now that's obviously in
reference to to Chelsea Handler again
again everyone has every right to make
every choice for themselves I am not
trying to uh to tell anyone to live any
way that they don't want to but there
are themes there are basic truths that
we all know to be true and I think part
of the reason we're so screwed up
culturally and politically and
everything else is everything that we
knew to be true 20 years ago seems to be
up for debate today
[Music]
thank you